Wa tuh tuh tuh  before this video begins I have another giveaway Excitement.
Yes from origin PC.
These have always been very popular so definitely make sure you join in this time
We're giving away the Evo 15s Gaming laptop
look at this beautiful thing
mwah
ah mich ah michelangelo
this bad boy feature not yet launched
HD UV textured printing by origin PC
so if you print a brofist on it
you will feel the brofist
Take a second and think about that
It's popping out so you can feel it in all its glory.
You can feel the textures of the print.
Origin PC
promised that they would send me one.
You'd better.
But to join the giveaway check out Origin PC.com/pewdiepie
and you could win one
Enjoy the video guys
*basic phone ringtone*
Bonjour!
Youtube. You tell Susan right now that
I don't care how many millions You want to give me for free
Haha. That's right.
The only thing I care moooreee about is my faaaaaans.
That's right. So just tell them it doesn't matter how much
my fans comes first, and I love them so much especially when they leave a like on this video
Ah ha hehehe! Oopsie!
I didn't see you at all! how long has this been recording?
Did you hear that? Puh
Wasn't even important
just standard Conversations I have
today if you didn't guess it already
We're gonna review the 'oops didn't mean to' subreddit.
*Slightly deeper voice* That's funny and original Felix. Did you come up with that yourself?
*furious clapping*
Stop being mean
(He's morphing into WoahVicky) STOP HATING
stop.
I love everybody
*snap snap snap snap snap*
Alright let's begin
Check out this barbecue sauce I bought a while back
wrong picture
That would be my dick. I'm sorry about that. Here: the correct picture
Oopsie,
didn't mean to send a picture of my ding-dong
OOOPSIEEE
Could happen to anyone I mean I always store my pictures of my barbecue sauce right next to my pictures of my ding-dong
It's a common thing. I always mix them up, except
one is kind of bigger than the others but oopsie
Youtuber Logan Paul says he didn't realize
tasers
electrocute things
OOPSIE, hehe
OOOPSIEEE
Did I just do an oopsie again, I didn't know, I just
Whowouldathought? Things just make an oopsie some times.
Caught myself trying to figure out portrait mode. This is me puzzled.
Good night
Goood nightt
OOPSIE
Listen up Johnny. You're not fooling anyone. This is not an oopsie
This is what I like to call in the Oopsie community a fake oopsie. this man is lying to you
This is a fake oopser, and I'll show him by smashing his face
Stupid making me angry. I don't want any fake oopser.
Now this, this is real when you take a picture by accident this should be good
When trying to screenshot something
I'm just gonna take a picture
OOPSIE
I'm just gonna take a screenshot
Now
Alright, so don't worry about it
Is this all this sub-reddit is going to be? Just people uh
posting selfies. Your nipples look weird, mate. You might want to check that out, okay?
Not interested. Great, another one. 'When you were just trying to show off your shoes in a picture
But people mistake it for you trying to get dudes in your DMs without having to actually say it'
Wow, I don't.. know.
Why? Maybe they're asking you 'where did you get those horachas?' let me just uh show you guys my socks
always wanted to show you
My
Socks here they are
Don't get any any weird ideas
Oopsie
Fucking no more selfies.
Please. Can't you just admit? Is it so hard to admit that you want to share a picture of yourself?
What the heck? ...<in dramatic voice> This was a total unintentional photo I took of myself
One of the first ones I ever took with my new camera
It's kind of metaphorical though. I'm in the captain's chair,
the driver seat. I can set the destination for my journey, and not just this small journey from one location to another,
I'm the captain of my life and I can set my
destination. <still in dramatic voice> There's backseat drivers yes, but with practice and determination
I'm learning how to shut those voices out--even my own voice sometimes. That voice can be the harshest.
But I can't let that weigh me down. Good vibes only, AM I RIGHT?
OOPSIEEE
Just shared about your thoughts again, didn't even plan that out.
'I was gonna reference Marxism
Marxism, but then no one would understand it.'
'Do it and then explain it.' 'It's so long and nerdy sksksksk
I'd have to explain the dialectic model, which has the thesis antithesis and
Synthesis scenario where the working class takes over through revolution. Crap I did it again'
OOPSIE
Spotted hard at work! Literally someone just sent me this photo from an unknown number
I'm creeped out, but also thankful to know that I look elegant...
Sleeping. You told your friend to send you that picture you rigged the whole thing. They're faking the game
They're faking the social media game. This is no longer an oopsie doopsie. It's a freaky
deaky
(Momentary spike in IQ level)
What is this, sound effect with ambience? puh.
Dumb
It's a demo
Sorry, I was hacked
OOPSIEEE
The number one defense in the "oopsie, didn't mean to" community is to claim that you've got somehow
Hacked and this is really just someone else that did it, not you
Dropping my new song Monday. If this gets a hundred thousand retweets
Thousand retweets. Uh by the way, my twitter got hacked
Somebody is threatening to release my new moosic I worked really hard onnn
Nothing comes out til I'm reaadyyy
OOPS. SIE.
Sure, my ex totally didn't mean to send me a selfie with her marriage certificate oops, sorry
Meant for someone else
OOPSIE
Oh how crazy, you can just click the wrong picture and then just everything just goes wrong.
Eating cereal and this happened completely by chance
Oh my I didn't even touch them I swear
Oops, sie.
Well you gotta appreciate the aesthetic or whatever. Not like I had anything to do with a Jesus beer change
Wanna fuck? I mean truck. Trying to help my buddy sell his F-150.
Sorry if you
OOPSIEE
I'm so sorry if you'd wanted to because that's definitely not what I am interested in okey
I'm just a man trying to sell a woman a truck here, okay
You gay son! Or at least your mom is
praying before we shot a video today my camera went off on a timer without me touching or programming it
so I thought that maybe the Lord wanted me to share that special candid moment
This is me praying with my girlfriend, and I did not set up a camera with a tripod in front of me
Oopsie-doopsie-oopsie It just, it was Jesus Christ. I took this out for himself
Okay, you mind if I praise God
Hahahahaha
Wrong titty
Oh
What?! That was not my girlfriend's tootie tata?!!
OOPSIEEE
Well this one is, they're just having a fun
I'm gonna let this one slide. Some people, some of you in the community might say
this is a faker daker, but no, it's an okay with me
Video chat soon. I want to get you nakey
Should have stopped at the video chat soon. I was about to say yes.
Oopsie! The last part was autocorrect.
I was trying to say I want to get you naked, not nakey. You silly goose. Hey guys so I
accidentally
Bought a Range Rover and now my mom is making me sell it. If anyone in Toronto wants to buy it please DM me. Thanks
How do you accidentally buy a car?
OOPSIEE
Oh, I just, I fell
I literally just fell and then I had the keys to the car in my hand. These things happen, you would understand.
Husband accidentally
You know, as soon as someone writes accidentally in a social post, then you just call bullshit right away
Yet perfectly caught one of the best moments and feelings ever in my lifetime. How can you hate this accident?
Oh, I mean OOPSIE
God damn it
Question mark. That was an accident. How did you accidentally send me a video of your dick?
No I was just messing with the camera and my dick happened to be out. I swear, haha
that was so random.
errrr oopsiee..
So random am I right everybody that was so random
*Pewds having a moment of cringe*
Just waving to the crowd
Yes, that's oh my god, I can totally relate to this. Whenever I did that it was an oopsie doopsie too.
Please. Please.
OOPSIEE
Can I have my show backkk
Please, Youtube.
Are you kidding me YouTube? I'm having a hard time receiving accurate notifications
for my actual subscribed channels and this crap pops up
I never once clicked a video of his, at least try to hide the favorism.
Logan Paul is back in notifications. Oh
Oopsie! Our bad! We fixed it so that only Logan subscribers will get it going forward
OOPSIEEE
Do you like anyone? Yeah, you. Uh I have a boyfriend. Yeah, you question mark.
OHH ah HA
ehhrrraaahtahhaahh OOPSIE
Woudn't it be great if you oopsie the like on this video and share it with all your family and friends and everyone that you know
oopsie
Alright guys. Hope you enjoyed and I'll see you guys next time
Finally done with this crap
Stupid idiots are gonna love this shit